a discussion on the u.s and global
economies
speakers include former congressman jim
colby of arizona
and pulitzer prize winner daniel jurgen
the new america foundation and the new
school host it's
about an hour
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for joining us today
my name is steve clemons i direct the
foreign policy programs at the new
america foundation a think tank here in
washington d.c
and we're very proud to be working with
the new school schwartz center for
economic policy analysis
and helping to support uh i think a
truly interesting
uh substantive discussion set of
conversations which
we will enjoy this morning we've worked
with a number of people in helping to
pull this program together i'm going to
introduce
one of the key players senator bob carey
it's great to have senator kerry back in
his
his stomping grounds here in the senate
uh but i also want to um
give special notice as i think senator
kerry will to
will millberg i'm going to point to will
over here who's an economist with the
schwartz center at the new school
who's been a very active partner in this
program and our hope here the new
america foundation organizes lots of
programs but
i love the new school programs and we'd
like to see the new school staff
ideas provocations here in washington
d.c as much as possible so we're very
very
grateful to be here and i just want to
say just in my uh
30 seconds that what we're trying to do
with this question of
will the economic sky fall is to
struggle
with the question of conventional
economic wisdom and how we approach and
think about
various sorts of deficits fragilities in
in the economic system both
internationally
and domestic and look at whether or not
there
are new features of the international
economic environment in american
economic environment that are not
figuring into
our calculations of of of how we sculpt
policy
and that's what this discussion about is
about sculpting policy but it's also
about
inputs into that decision and whether or
not uh
uh we should uh alter our course
based on some of these questions i don't
want to be overly crude in what we're
doing but to some degree we've brought
together
just a phenomenal roster of of highly
talented i call them high octane public
intellectuals writers thinkers
journalists
to struggle uh with these ideas and to
some degree
we've brought together the doom and
gloomers with some optimists and we'll
see how this comes out
but please give a round of applause to
our partner senator bob carey
president of the new school who who is
really needs no introduction here in
this building but
please welcome senator bob terry
well i'm uh also i want to uh
thank uh steve and the new american
foundation i want to thank bernard
schwartz uh
for coming up with the idea and coming
up with the money
necessary to not only put this
discussion on but
other discussions as well uh on the
question of whether or not conventional
wisdom is right
i want to thank will millberg who is
senior economist at
the schwartz center and at the new
school uh
uh he has been a terrific partner in all
of this
uh and and putting these conferences on
and well i very much appreciate
the work that you've done to make this
possible
uh i i do kind of remember what it's
like to face a political audience and i
i don't consider this to be one this
morning
um but uh it's hard to stand before an
audience without
sort of still after you've been for 16
years not thinking
as if you're still trying to get votes
in 1988 when i first ran for the senate
i remember very well debating dave
carnes who was the incumbent republican
senator at the time
and we were debating on national
security uh uh
uh uh as if the cold war was gonna go on
forever
uh we debated the mx missile uh we
debated uh what our nuclear posture
ought to be to prevent a bullet out of
the blue attack
uh we debated how to defend ourselves
against the soviet union we
debated what we're going to be doing
with eastern european dictators
uh the presumption was that that was
going to go on for a very very
uh long time uh and i arrive
in the was sworn into office by george
herbert walker bush
uh and 10 months later we find that the
presumptions of that campaign were
completely wrong
um devastatingly wrong in many ways we
spent half a dozen years celebrating
this
great victory and struggling to try to
figure out what was going to happen now
that that
power center had collapsed now likewise
in the 1990s the the dominant
metric that you use to judge whether or
not you were doing a good job in
congress is whether or not we were
making progress on the deficit
eliminating the deficit was i would say
broadly seen by republicans and
democrats as an economic imperative
and there were very few dissenting
opinions in the 1990s on that point
and indeed that argument predated the
1990s
republicans had a balanced budget
amendment that they were proposing to
the united states constitution
it was a difficult proposition i
remember very very well
uh when uh uh
that amendment failed in the united
states senate by a single vote
uh in 1995 or 1996 somewhere in that in
that time period
so it was it was accepted wisdom and it
still uh lingers on today
the trade deficit uh is seen as a
parallel
problem identified constantly as a
parallel problem and what bernard
uh and i uh have have come to believe is
that it's entirely possible conventional
wisdom is wrong
that those two metrics all by themselves
that if we solve that problem
instead of making things better we may
make things worse and
what we hope to do with this and other
conferences and other discussions like
that is
give the political leadership uh some
opportunity
some space in which they can consider
whether or not conventional wisdom is
right or wrong and what they can devise
the right economic strategy coming out
of washington it is exceptionally
difficult to do
uh democracy uh i don't have to tell all
of you this but but
believe me it's more difficult than you
think uh
oftentimes uh you're you're entirely
at the mercy of public opinion and
public opinion can swing
back and forth unmercifully after you've
staked out a position that is popular
you find yourself
two years later in an unpopular position
of having to face public opinion down so
it is exceptionally difficult and very
very important to try to provide
an opportunity for debates to go on
about things as important as what are
the fundamental metrics that we ought to
use to guide ourselves in the united
states congress are making decisions
about
things that need to be done in order to
keep the united states of america's
economy growing jobs being created
wealth being generated income being
increased as well as
well distributed and people being
relatively satisfied that whatever it is
that washington dude can to improve
uh the the the prosperity of the country
is being done
exceptionally well uh i think uh steve
you're going to introduce the
the the first panel so i'll just pass it
back over to you thank you
thank you
senator perry will be back to moderate a
fascinating discussion with senator bob
bennett senator debbie stavenow and
senator kent conrad as well
and to participate in the discussions
there's no one that i can think of
better than than two other moderators uh
uh and i will out them because they
happen to be married but that has
nothing to do with them both being here
but the first is sebastian maliby
uh of course who's the uh paul volcker
senior fellow for international
economics at the council on foreign
relations
and he has a regular piece of op-ed real
estate in the washington post
where he's become one of the most
considered one of the most economic
important economic writers uh framers of
policy
and and and discussions on these issues
in in the country so
on the subject of is the economic sky
falling
sebastian malbe will moderate and then
this afternoon
we'll have zany mitten bettos uh chief
economics
writer for the economist here in
washington dc joining us well so
the floor is now sebastian malibi
sebastian
okay so the premise here is that uh
you've been around washington a while
you've been to lots of these sessions
we've got the coming crisis in
healthcare the coming crisis in u.s
china relations
the coming crisis in our education
system in our retirement system you name
the subject we can build a crisis
scenario around it
the new crisis today is that we are too
obsessed with crises
um and so we're going to reconsider all
this stuff
uh and uh we've got a great uh cast of
characters we've got
daniel jurgen here who of course
combines being a successful entrepreneur
with a private surprise-winging
author we've got doug holzikin who
is the chief economic advisor on the
mccain campaign formerly head of the
congressional budget office
and also the council of foreign
relations we've got
the honourable jim colby who is now
dividing his time between the german
marshall fund and kissinger
mclarty associates that sounds like
intellectual satisfaction
and another kind of satisfaction
formerly of course
a prominent member of the house active
on trade and also on aid
we have mike mandel who is the chief
economist for business week we have
clyde prestowitz
who is the president of the economic
strategy institute and an expert on
east asian affairs and we've got james
galbraith from the lbj
school of public affairs at the
university of texas at austin now
my first guinea pig uh is going to be
the most optimistic of all the people on
the panel the most
anti-crisis that is mike mandel uh well
known in business week for saying that
the sky will never fall
um mike um i i just
uh asked you a bit of a general question
um
i mean do you do you think it's right
that people exaggerate
uh the possibility of various kinds of
bad things happening to the u.s economy
and in particular
is there a negative consequence from
that pessimism
well look there's this we're here to say
mike and
we're here to talk about the budget
deficit and the trade deficit so let me
just focus on those
uh people worry about the budget deficit
and what you and what you see a couple
of things that the main impact of the
budget deficit is supposed to be on
interest rates and you don't
see that it's supposed to be on
squeezing down corporate investment and
corporations seem to have plenty of
money
the negative effect of worrying about
the budget deficit
and this is always true whenever
congress gets into a budget deficit
cutting mood
the first thing that goes is r d and
education spending
i've gone back and looked at this you
know in hard times
and tough times the uh the um
what's the most dispensable thing what's
the thing with the least number of
constituents
it's it's r d this at r d in education
spending and if you
go back to the early clinton years you
see weakness in r d spending and you see
it now as well
so what happens is by worrying about the
budget deficit what we end up
cutting our seed corn the trade deficit
i think
brings up a slightly different set of
questions one set of questions is
are we heading for a global financial
crisis
and uh you know i think that crises do
occur but i think if there was a global
financial crisis it would be more likely
to hit in china
than it would be here if you sort of ask
the global financial system is stressed
if it's stressed where is it more likely
to break it's more likely to break in
the place with the worst financial
system which is china than it is
than it is here i actually want to
correct one
misconception here i don't think
that bad things never happen i just
think
that the bad things
that we expect are not the ones that
actually occur
so there we are mike uh from business
week is a perfect example of the way
that journalists spend their time
including myself sort of you know
describing other people when they get
described
of course they push back that's all
right um
clyde questions now um
uh clyde you've written um books about
japan books about china
um they of course are well known for
building growth
particularly in the japanese case i
guess on massive public investment
and on direction of private sector
investment
do you think that there's something to
this discussion that
if we lost some of our fear of budget
deficits and went
in a bigger way for investment we would
do better
well i think that the the budget deficit
question can't be really discussed
unless you
are discussing national savings um if
you have high net
japan for example i ran in the 1990s
enormous budget deficits
but japan financed those deficits
because it has high savings
financed them domestically the us is a
low-saving country
so the consequence of budget deficits
for us is that we borrow money from
abroad to finance
our our deficit and to finance our
consumption
and uh there's a lot of money abroad the
chinese and japanese and the saudis
are swimming in in money and so they
lend to us
but this means of course that we're
accumulating uh liabilities
and and so in answer to the question uh
is the sky falling i guess i would say
and the sky's not falling now it could
fall
um in fact i'm reminded of i i feel
in this discussion i feel like i kind of
felt in
1999 and 2000 remember when cisco was
selling for 120
dollars a share and uh and
and dot com stocks were just a one-way
bit uh and everybody was talking about
the new economy
and how everything was different but it
turned out that you could have a crash
or i remember long-term capital
management
they had the smartest guys on wall
street they had nobel prize winners
writing their
trading algorithms and they made the
right bet
they made the right bet it's just their
timing was off and it turned out that
hedge funds could go belly up
so the sky could fall and
uh and i agree with mike it'll happen in
a way you haven't thought about
it'll always be something unexpected but
you know if you talk to tim geithner at
the fed in new york he's kind of worried
about derivatives markets
uh nobody seems to know where the risk
is and nobody seems to know who the
counterparties are
uh and so that combined with
what i see as a stealth move already
away from the dollar number of central
banks are limiting their dollar holdings
moving to euros
uh you could i could fall but
actually the worst thing in my view is
if the sky doesn't fall
uh and because because this whole
discussion it seems to me is premised on
the notion that you don't have to pay
for what you what you consume in other
words you can run budget deficits and
you don't have to pay
i mean i don't know why we have an irs
if budget deficits don't matter
we don't need taxes just print the money
uh
and if uh and and
it's the same thing so so i guess my
concern is that
we actually go along as we are
uh accumulating liabilities which of
course
they have to be financed and so this
becomes a long-term
tax on future generations right so okay
so the problem with debt
is that ultimately you have to pay it
back now i want to go to james galbraith
the question i suppose which people have
raised is that
um we've been borrowing we've been
running this kind of count deficit for
very long time
lately it's gotten even bigger than it
was in the 1990s
doubled as a show of gdp roughly and
the sky still hasn't fallen does this
mean it still has to fall one day or
could we go on like this for a while and
in particular
just to tie it back to the earlier
discussion of public
infrastructure investment could one
argue
that in the 1980s east asian
economies financed uh in investment
through plentiful cheap savings now
uh these plentiful cheap savings from
the chinese
are globalized hence extremely low
interest rates globally
and also from the recycling of oil
revenues from the petrol states
given these global capital markets and
the willingness of foreigners to hold
us instruments couldn't we
take our 90s 1980s lenses off and say to
ourselves well
there's cheap capital before other
people used it now we can use it
we can go on an investment spree and in
the long term that will boost our growth
rate does that make sense or not i think
the
my short answer to that is yes
but i'd arrive at it by a slightly
different route i would say
that we will be judged
20 years or a generation from now by
our ability to address our material
problems
by whether we create jobs whether we
reduce poverty
whether we cope with climate change
whether we deal with
social issues whether we deal with our
infrastructure deficits
that's what the future will judge us by
the question we face is whether we're
limited in our ability to address
those concerns by financial factors
including the international
financial factor that you just mentioned
i think the answer that is that we are
not
immediately limited in any material way
by international or domestic financial
factors neither
by the budget deficit nor by the
internet deficit in the international
accounts
the chinese are accumulating uh
u.s treasury bonds as reserves for
reasons
of their own and they're basically two
of those reasons
one is that it helps them
their export trades help them to manage
a process of urbanization which is the
fundamental problem of chinese
development the fundamental thrust of
chinese development
and the second is that they have a lot
of money coming in
to basically to speculate in the chinese
markets including real estate but also
stocks
uh which they're sterilizing and turning
into dollars and they're holding those
dollars they have no
particular use for those dollars and so
it's in some sense a kind of passive
process
and the balance between in our
trade account ultimately is not zero
there's no tendency in the long run for
us to have to reduce our trade deficit
to any fixed
figure the balance is in the world
system between
the number the value of the bonds that
everyone out there wishes to hold
and the value that we wish to issue and
there's no telling exactly
at any given moment where that balance
lies except to say
that it hasn't caused us any serious
trouble yet and the way you can
gauge that is by looking at the
long-term interest rate the federal
reserve has raised short-term
interest rates repeatedly until it
stopped doing so recently
but the long-term interest rate has
hardly budged and that's
in other words even if you take the view
that there is potentially a risk that
one day this current account deficit
becomes unsustainable
the point is that that's not a certain
problem
exactly whereas we have certain problems
on the other side of the ledger in terms
of a lack of investment
exactly and i would say it's not the
current account deficit per se that we
should be worried about but as clyde
just put it
it is the stability of the overall
international financial systems
international financial systems do
occasionally collapse they crumble they
have to be rebuilt
periodically we have to worry about that
problem but it shouldn't constrain us
from doing what we need
i'd like to bring in jim colby
particularly since i think you might
have to leave slightly early
um now you have
more political experience than the rest
of us put together
exactly and sometimes people make the
argument that the real risk
to continued prosperity is not so much
something that might go on out there in
the private sector
it's that the government the political
system uh
may decide that it can't tolerate
something which in fact is crucial to
continued growth
it could be that um there's a clampdown
on
cross-border movement both of people and
of goods you've got the ciphers issue
concerns over security could get in the
way it could be that the consensus in
favor of globalization and trade
disintegrates uh for for political
for political reasons driven by growing
income inequality
do you see political risks to the
continued uh success of the system
sure yeah i think there are political
risks so
the sky isn't falling but i do see sure
do see some cracks up there
uh in this sky and it's long term the
problem is
too many politicians and for frankly
economists and others
sometimes cry wolf and people get jaded
and they don't believe that
uh i'm the political risks i'm not as
concerned about the political risk of
what
congress or politicians or executive
branch might do but what they might
not do and when i say that i'm thinking
of one thing in particular and that is
i think the long-term risk to the
economy
is the growth of entitlements and ah the
unwillingness
of the congress which is reflective of
the american people
to really come to grips with what is a
massive problem
and it's it we've really only seen the
beginning of this problem because now as
the baby boomers start to retire
it's going to become massive and if we
don't focus on that and deal with social
security medicare medicaid
those big things that are gobbling up so
much the deficit
we're not going to have anything left
for that seed corn that was being talked
about here earlier
we're not going to have anything left to
make the investments in education we're
out in
r d and health and the other kinds of
things they are we're going to be
consumed with
our entire budget being a transfer
payment to one class of citizens to
senior citizens yeah but jim you could
just
just print the money i mean the deficits
don't matter so just borrow it in front
of them
well let's get let's let's get we could
print it indefinitely but i think that
eventually i think deficits do matter
doug holtzeken is both
the former director of the budget office
uh and also now
um a political advisor um so
why don't you come in on this uh well i
am a big jim colby fan because
number one he said that the people have
become jaded about economists and that
suggests that they once listened to us
and that's i find that incredibly hard
um and because i think he's right about
the the core problem uh
if you uh step back and do the
the the analysis in the boring fashion
that is politically unappealing
uh what we what we should do is identify
the national problems and priorities
that we would like so we would like to
have
an economy that continues to grow raise
standards of living
you then figure out which part is the
government's role
what what it can do in the way of
regulations in the way of diplomacy and
trade negotiations what it can do in the
way of government spending programs
to foster that goal and then at the end
you figure out how to finance it and the
financing uh
turns out to look like a budget deficit
or an international context a current
account deficit
that's that's the tail and uh focus
a discussion that focuses on the tail
and whether the tail should be a two or
a four is an entirely misplaced
discussion
a two or four what do you mean a number
let's pick a number let's make it
smaller let's make it bigger
it's it's the wrong focus uh the focus
should be on
our goal our goal is to prosper in the
future to do that we need to set up
aside sufficient seed corn
to educate our young to uh finance
innovation
we now spend more on innovation and
intangibles than we do on physical
investment in the united states but also
to build the buildings and factories we
need for the future
to do that we need to consume less and
the core issue
is the one that uh congressman coleman's
identified which is
we have enormous government programs
whose purpose whose state of purpose is
to make people consume more now
and to not put aside sufficient
resources for the future and they're out
of control
so if we want to patch the biggest crack
we should take care of the entitlements
and the sky will not fall so in other
words to uh to move
to move in the direction of more
productive investment
the thing is not to print money as uh
clyde was suggesting possibly
facetiously uh but but in fact just to
reign in consumption
and and one way of doing that is to get
a handle on entitlements yeah it's the
single most direct handle that the
government has
is the self-inflicted problem from these
large programs uh we should start there
and that doesn't suggest it's the only
thing but should always solve the
biggest problem first
now for this side of the room we have a
secret weapon uh who is dan juergen who
is hiding behind this lecture so he's
going to move down there now
where he will become visible we will
reveal our secret
um and as he's walking along and ask him
a question
i think i'll start bring you over to the
subject on which
you're best known which is of course
energy and oil
you've written rather persuasively that
this concern that uh oil production
would peak
um and uh
with that we've reached the peak and
therefore we're moving into a world of
declining oil supplies
uh this this worry comes up repeatedly
in history is always proven wrong
because of new technology
and so my question is you know does this
concern about
peak oil it may be wrong but is it
in fact useful in the sense that it
persuades people to think
about alternative energy or is it
dysfunctional because
out of this misguided concern for peak
oil
you wind up with dysfunctional policies
with this complicated microphone broken
you broke it already
go ahead
uh sebastian as you suggest
i would say that this is uh not the
first time that we've run out of oil
this is the fifth time
and uh each time technology new areas
have
have opened it up i think that
is it useful well it certainly is very
motivating it certainly is a big
stimulus to
renewables uh part of the risk of it
though
is if you pin your hat on that and then
events don't turn out that way
then you lose the momentum that you
actually do need to address these
these broader questions i think what
we're seeing is
uh in terms of energy is really what is
a
is a subset of what bernard schwartz has
pointed to
which is uh it's it's really
infrastructure it's bottlenecks that are
determining
what we're seeing right now uh and
uh in time markets expenditures uh
will will resolve those but i think
what's also new
i think the second thing that the peak
oil reflects
is this sense that we have this major
surge of demand going on in the world
and that uh and this has happened before
with china
and india and that really what we're
really seeing in terms of prices now
is some disruption but mainly it's a
result of success as a result of what
we're talking about before it's the
success of globalization and economic
growth
that's driving where we are and i do
think
markets respond and technology responds
right now
uh c would have sort of dubbed the great
bubbling
which is not a reference to champagne
but it's reference to this kind of
technological innovation
that you see occurring all along the
energy spectrum
and um to go back to what senator
kerry said the unexpected will happen
and we ought to expect the unexpected we
don't know the timing of it
but i think that three or four years
from now things will look different
in the energy picture than they do today
i have another question for you which
kind of is a mixture of
a subject which came up earlier an
energy which is this question of you
know financial crisis there can be a
crisis as
uh mike was reminding me um
and one kind of crisis people fear is a
financial crisis and the most recent
sort of hiccup we had was in energy
training when amaranth
the hedge fund blew up last year and
lost six billion dollars rather quickly
um in that particular case the system
absorbed it
extremely easily there was almost no
collateral damage as far as most people
could see
in your knowledge and in energy markets
obviously in the california case as well
throughout another version of a sort of
financial
malfunction um do you see
uh in energy particularly but in other
traded markets
more broadly um are you worried that uh
something will blow up or wake up with
another ltcm the fed will have to
intervene
well let me say california although it's
remembers the financial
uh crisis it was really again an
infrastructure crisis
california economy had grown by 29 and
no new electric power plants had been
built
and they basically ran short of
electricity i was thinking as i was
listening to the discussion in the world
of energy uh you really it is dominated
by shortages right now shortages of
engineers shortages of
refining equipment uh shortages of
commodities with this incredible boom in
china and elsewhere in the world
one thing we don't have today is a
shortage of money a shortage of
liquidity and thus these low interest
rates we've been talking about
one of two things will happen either it
will go on forever or
won't and when it won't the economic
landscape
will change i don't
claim to have special knowledge probably
tim geithner has
more knowledge the concerns about
derivatives
but in financial markets and other
markets
clearly there are vast developments
going on that people don't have a grasp
over but i think other people
on the panel might have a view but
i don't see why there won't be financial
crises of one kind or another
at some point in the future and when
they happen they will come as a surprise
and it will be a name that we
most of us have never heard of and
afterwards it will be explained why it
was all obvious and inevitable that was
going to happen
and i guess the question is though how
quickly we absorb that crisis and
in the amaranth case the interesting
thing is it was absorbed extremely
quickly
you have to and that does have to do
with so much liquidity
and so much money and the depths of the
markets
uh but often when you look at crises to
go back to your uh
abundance of crises it's not that one
thing happens
but it's that three or four things
happen at the same time and come
together
jim colby do you have time to one more
thing let me ask you
so just going back to the earlier
discussion and picking up the thread a
little bit
um i suppose one thing which is emerging
is this idea that when it comes to tax
cuts
uh your party the republican party has
been frequently willing to say
look uh we want to go for growth here
we're willing to tax
cut cut the taxes and uh
getting the growth from the tax cut
matters more than
fiscal uh the fiscal problem
uh why isn't the same politically
speaking why hasn't the same argument
and i'm not saying that that's the
generalization by all members of your
party of course not
but at least a wing of the party has
been willing to say that
but so why is it that there hasn't been
the similar argument about
infrastructure hey
let's make more infrastructure
investment let's make more educational
investment
we're willing to tolerate some deficit
for that why is that a less popular kind
of
there should be there's no question that
that's exactly where
republicans and democrats for that
matter ought to be talking about that if
we're going to have deficits that's what
we ought to be making
the investment why don't they do it i
can the answer that's simple
we run on two-year terms senators run on
six-year terms governors run on
four-year terms presidents run on
four-year terms
and they're thinking about the next
election and you don't get usually get a
lot of popularity you don't get a lot of
votes out of suggesting
long-term investments in education
boring you don't get a lot of of
interest among the public by talking
about
long-term investments in r d ho hum
but if you're going to talk about making
a transfer payment a new program for
veterans if you're going to talk about a
new
uh program for senior citizens a drug
prescription program or whatever
now you're talking about people who are
going to be voting for me in the next
election and and so it's a matter of the
short term versus the long term
that's the political dilemma we have
today our problems are
increasingly our long-term ones that
we're facing out there increasingly the
horizon
for politicians seems to be much more
short-term
than it ever did before just because of
the nature of of the
internet of the communications that we
have things are instantaneous
and people expect instantaneous results
and instantaneous
things to happen and so politicians seem
to be on a much shorter time leash
than they were before while the problems
seem to be out there in the future
so it's the same reason we don't have
entitlement reform in other words it's
just too long
entitlement reform is you know everybody
knows it needs to be done you can't find
one
politician if you took him aside on in a
corner some here every place here and
talked about and says
yeah we really need to do something
about it but you know maybe after the
next election
we'll think about that one well there's
always the next election
and and so people just don't think about
it it's always something postpone it
until there is something of a crisis
down the road and to me that's a
puzzling thing
because other countries now they don't
have the huge entire most of them don't
have
the huge overlay of entitlement problems
that we do in this country
but other countries have dealt with this
they do have a political system that
allows them to deal with that there's
any number of countries you can talk
about who've have reformed their pension
system
and to some extent their health care
systems made major reforms in those
things and been willing to do it and
done it without too much political
disaster occurring to people either can
i offer a point
yes sir comment on this i think when we
discuss entitlements we should always
break it into its two
major components and i would argue that
social security is fundamentally sound
and that there is no compelling case for
major cuts in social security benefits
and in my view there's no case for any
cuts in social security benefits
on the other hand medical medicaid on
the other hand medicare and medicaid
are part of a much larger problem which
is the cost of health care
and that is an important issue but one
which needs to be dealt with
not as a problem of a government program
but as a problem of the health care
system
as a whole including the role of private
insurance and the fact that we don't
have
any effective means for managing the
costs and the rising costs
of that system but we can't deal with
that as a medicare
issue the worst part about medicare part
d was not that it extended a drug
benefit
that it did so in a way which permitted
big
pharmaceutical companies to make
inordinate profits off
of the sale of those prescription
medications
since i'm probably i'm going to have to
leave in just a couple of minutes let me
just get one thought in here i agree
that the
the health care the medicare and
medicaid are much more much bigger
they're humongous
compared to social security and and
jamie's right that it's the
what's driving it is the uncertainties
of health care costs and we don't know
really where we're
going with health care but i do disagree
that social security is not a problem
so social security is a problem and to
me it's the laboratory
if we don't have the political will to
do anything to fix social security
uh and you've got it on both the revenue
side and the liabilities over the long
term
there is no question that if you look at
social security
in the next horizon of 30 40 50 years
that all the baby boomers retire and
go to their graves we're going to be
facing a smaller
group of people paying into the social
security system a larger group receiving
the benefits
there is a problem it's fixable it's
very fixable
but there's no political will to do it
that's i
would just say i think there is a
problem well thank you very much
mike you are shaking your head let me
let me actually be the outlier here
move it over here let me be the outlier
here and say that i actually am not
you sort of say you can't find anybody
who doesn't believe that there's a
medicare
medical problem i don't believe i don't
believe that there's a long-term
medicare problem in the same way that
other people do
we're talking about 50-year projections
and of a
projection of a particular sort if you
hold those
paths you know a little bit of extra
productivity growth 50 years out
ends up turning what looks like an
enormous yawning problem to something
much more manageable
that's not to say that there i've had
she had this discussion with doug before
okay you were wrong the first time oh
come on
i'm not real okay i may not be right but
i'm not wrong
two different things uh you think about
50-year production
distinction well you know it's about
it's about uncertainty
and and faith versus prudence and so
forth um
i think that i think that if you think
about
50-year projections and if you look go
back to 1950 and you'd ask what things
were going to look like in 2000
i'm not sure you would have gotten very
many of the uh correct
correct guesses at that point uh there's
a
i think the right way to think about
health care system is the things that
need to be fixed
but that if you have gains in
productivity growth it becomes much
easier to pay for it
dark well i i'm not sure i agree
entirely with mr mandela however much i
might respect him um
first um uh let's remember that
uh this isn't all about the financing
and the fact that there's a mismatch
between dedicated
revenues and these these programs and
the outlays
the problems are deeper and bigger than
that in social security
even if you don't address the
fundamental imbalance in the financing
and that is real
we have promised seven percent of our
national income in social security
benefits as far as the eye can see
we have the political will to finance
five percent of our national income
there's a two percentage point gap
forever and so that
that's not a program that's in good
shape uh but even if you ignore that
this is a program that has bad
incentives it actually uh
deters saving in the united states it
doesn't help it it makes it worse
it's targeted poorly we have people who
are divorced and
on ineligible for benefits one day later
had they remained married for another
day they get benefits
it is available in ways that make no
sense
across the income distribution and so it
needs fixed regardless of the financing
and it would produce better economic
incentives better social outcomes
medicare and medicaid are a reflection
of the health care system but the
federal government pays 50
of the health care bills so if you want
to find the problem just look right
around this town
and this town micromanages health care
and we independent again at the
financing
have problems in health we spend 16
percent of our national income on a
health
system that does not produce better
outcomes than much cheaper systems
and it is financed in a way that puts
people at risk for loss in their
financial
coverage when they lose their job uh
leaves them unhappy
with their financial outcomes after they
are sick
these are all big problems they need to
be addressed
and they are fundamentally under
financed on top of that so
i don't think you can make the claim
they're fine and in health
in particular the idea we can grow our
way out of it is always
very enticing but this one simply gets
too big
too fast to ever grow our way out of
health care spending per person is
rising two and a half percentage points
faster
than income per capita it would take a
productivity boom
of unprecedented proportions twice
anything that anyone could imagine
for the productivity to make up for the
healthcare growth we need to come to
terms with the problem not pray for a
productivity miracle
yes done i suppose uh sitting here on
the ninth floor at the top floor
uh we should probably have greater
sensitivity than the other floors onto
the question is whether the sky is
falling
and uh so to i mean so we've identified
kind of one set of issues that do or do
not affect it
uh i'd like to suggest a second but it
goes back to you
to your point sebastian because you were
really asking is there something
different in the scale and the
flexibility of the financial markets now
and the overall economy that it can
absorb any kind of shock that
comes along because you know if you look
at kind of trends you'd say a lot of the
tr
economic trends in the world are
actually very positive imagine germany
is
is growing now germany is a locomotive
of europe it's uh
this a year and a half ago one would
have expected a lot of positive trends
in economics
but if you look around the world you
have to say that there are a number of
very negative geopolitical trends uh
including
the reality of anti-americanism as a
political force around the world
and one question maybe is do do those
to events that are outside markets do
they have the ability to really
impact markets or do we have such
resilience that
go through anything that's a good
question i mean it is quite striking
that
i think one of the most volatile period
in financial markets
in the last say 10 years was right after
the
tech bubble crash in other words right
before
the terrorist attacks of 2001 so at a
period of maximum u.s power maximum sort
of confidence
on the geopolitical side there was
maximum nervousness on the financial
market side then it turned around
we have extreme fear from um people who
are involved in the security
side of our policy making that there
will be another terrorist attack that
iraq is going badly iran is a problem
almost anywhere you look
you've got a majority don't forget latin
america
right and and at the same time
volatility is incredibly low
uh in in stock markets yeah sure step in
here man make a difference
you know you can have you can have
things going wrong and still not have
the sky flaw
okay you could have the period that
comes you could have booms and busts
you could have real estate busts you can
even have subprime crises
okay and it doesn't mean the sky is
falling it doesn't mean that the system
is coming apart
okay and so what you want to think about
here is there anything going you know
there's good times and there's bad times
okay and
things may get better things that work
things get better the question is is
there anything going on
that could break the system can you
answer that right now yeah i mean okay
right right now i
i you know it right now in the from the
u.s side it looks pretty good
and from the and from the chinese side
they're sitting on a trillion dollars in
reserves
to help soak up whatever financial
problems you have
and so i think that uh you're you raised
a good point about the geopolitical
issues
as being the kind of the thing that may
be sort of more suspicious here
let me let me jump in sure on that
because i think there is something that
we should be
thinking about that maybe a breaker and
that is that
um if you look at the structure of the
global economy there's one
center one major center of net demand
that's of course the united states
or to broaden it let's say the
anglo-countries the brits the americans
and the aussies basically are net
buyers everybody else is a net seller
we in the u.s are consuming six seven
percent of gdp
more than we produce uh we're spending
more than we earn
so if you
if you argue it seems to me if you argue
that
there's nothing to worry about implicit
in that
is the assumption that one special set
of people the americans
can indefinitely consume more than they
produce
and somehow not pay for it the flip side
of this
is that very large parts of the world
are investing at an enormous rate i mean
china
50 of every dollar in china spent is a
new factory
uh singapore a similar kind of thing
it's a small economy but
nevertheless uh very high investment
rates
which are predicated upon the notion
that you can kind of expand production
forever
and sell it uh to the anglos
now in the past we saw economies like
japans and koreas
pursue a similar track and wind up with
enormous excess capacity
they were relatively small countries
we're now talking about some major
countries
trying to do the same thing and it seems
to me that the assumption that the
americans can consume forever and not
pay for it
and that the chinese can invest at 50
forever and not have
some kind of a crisis i mean that's
i think a fundamental issue to consume
i'd like to go to uh
questions uh from the floor in in a
second but uh
james galbraith wants to say one thing i
think this raises a very
deep question which is really whether
the world
needs the united states to perform a
role
in the world economy in the world
security that justifies the financial
position that we've been accorded
and we have over the past 50 years
largely fulfilled such a role as both
the guarantor
of stability and as a kind of beacon of
democracy and prosperity and other
ideals
we have to face the question whether we
are still
filling that role whether we are
in the process of squandering or perhaps
have already squandered
part or all of the moral authority that
the world
vested in us and whether we need to take
steps
to rebuild in some sense a multilateral
system
in which we can again enjoy the kind of
respect and the kind of authority
that permits us to continue to serve as
the financial anchor
as well as the security anchor of the
world system
it seems to me that if we don't do that
if we don't take that problem seriously
in other words if we don't
integrate our foreign policy problems
and here i'll mention the word that
hasn't been said
yet this morning iraq uh if we don't
cope with the kinds of issues that have
been raised by the conduct of foreign
policy
we are running risks of exactly the kind
that dan jurgen raised and other people
have raised
geopolitical risks that are the true
potential triggers for instability
and uh crisis in the world financial
system
so uh successful foreign policy and
accessible economic policy are
interlinked and we have a question right
here
hi martin hutchinson i write a column
called the bears lair
from which you'll be surprised uh not at
all to realize that my view is that the
sky is falling
it just hasn't landed yet my
quest my question in particular is
you've got two things i think that
have happened but not yet work them out
one is the housing crisis which i think
is much bigger than people think it's
uh being and you're talking i think a
trillion dollars of losses
and the second is venezuelan seizure of
the ordinary coil fields
which is 34 percent of world oil
reserves
larger than the middle east and suddenly
we've lost our oil security
if there wasn't another obvious buyer it
wouldn't matter but there is of course
this china
and they can go in there sort out the
oriental care fields take the lot off
and make us entirely dependent on the
middle east and i would suggest that the
loss of security and the financial crash
of housing
are both bits where bits of the sky have
come loose and are falling on us but
haven't landed
so uh daniel do you want to do the oil
part of that i thought i'd do the
housing
i'll do it yeah fine sure go right ahead
well i think what you point out what
happened uh was that last week in
venezuela
uh was both uh significant in itself and
uh quite symbolic of the change uh and
this goes back
to sebastian's question about peak oil
actually i'm glad you asked that
question because i'm trying to finish a
chapter on that subject this weekend so
your question is very helpful
uh but i do think that there are plenty
of risks above ground
plenty of risk and you've pointed to one
of the biggest uh
you know we've been preoccupied with the
middle east what's happening there but
the changes in latin america
led by venezuela part of the backlash
against globalization
uh socialism for the 21st century are
really very
uh significant now needs to be kept in
balance are actually although i think
many people
think that most of our oil imports i
mean you don't but most of our oil
imports come from the middle east
actually only 19 percent come from the
middle east and our number one
source of oil and energy imports is
canada
which i don't believe is an imminent
threat to u.s national security
if there are any canadians in the room
we can check on that mexico
okay yes that's right uh uh a sneaky
uh bunch is mexico so there's
you know there's diversification but
nevertheless uh venezuela since world
war ii has been
seen as a reliable supplier and if we
look at the world oil market it's not
only
tight supply because of economic growth
it's also there's a kind of aggregate
disruption
and the declines in venezuela are part
of that and uh the political agenda over
the economic
so i think that goes uh that set of
risks that set of geopolitical risks
above ground
uh are going are going to loom larger uh
in the years ahead at least so far as as
long as we remain in a high price
environment
housing i think somebody else should doc
do you want to take a record i
i i think the the subprime
mortgage uh debacle has uh
you know had clear stresses on
particular
uh communities and particular households
but it is not
uh broadly a threat to the u.s economy
uh
the it's important to remember the scale
of of the
issue and this is uh an issue that
affects a very small subset of american
households uh the vast majority of
homeowners don't even have a mortgage
not the vast majority but majority
and it's only in the past couple of
years that we've seen the rise in the
subprimes as a fraction of mortgage
lending
so their problems uh are real
but they are not typical of the american
household and you have to drive the
american household
uh spending uh substantially south in
order to generate large
uh economic problems in the united
states and there's no evidence of that
uh on the books yet but if congress was
to worry too much about this
uh potential meltdown would that have a
negative outcome
can would it lead congress down the
wrong policy path well i mean
there are two channels by which you can
make a problem that's targeted on these
households bigger and one channel is for
there to be a financial channel a
financial crisis of the type that that
others have mentioned
uh to do that you have to get some some
big lending institutions in
problems with their capital base and and
that's there's no uh
evidence of capital impairment out there
so they're not going to cut back on
loans to businesses and elsewhere
so i don't think we get that or bad
policy and uh bad policy is always a
risk uh
and here the right policy is to put in
place standards that
would have been appropriate to begin
with that's already taking place that
are broadly
uh broad enough to affect all the
lenders and there are new
exotic lenders as well as new exotic
instruments in this market we've got to
get those
and certainly to uh prosecute the fraud
and
uh there's some evidence of fraud in
this those should be people should be
hold accountable and send the message
that we're not gonna do business this
way
another question uh right there
why don't we take a couple you had a
question too so why don't you go a red
head out of this and
we'll take one more here and then we'll
have three questions lined up
okay there's been several discussions
and talks and views of whether or not
the sky is falling or something is going
to happen but there's agreement
something's going to happen in a way
that's
we've never anticipated but then
hindsight will say
oh we saw all the signs and indicators
number two someone brought up iraq
and um so was the 911
you know it took us by total surprise
but then as we look back
there were indicators so my question to
you is to imagine to consider
what might be the um analogy or
counterpart to an economic
role of terrorism of comparable like the
world trade center because we were
talking a lot today about
governmental uh actions but what
happened in 911
was like free agents or maybe with
government uh okay
uh so what might be how what will we
look at
for things that are weak that may be
vulnerable good that's a nice simple
question predict the unpredictable but
we'll go to the next question
thanks um specifically for mr jurgen but
for everyone else if you
care to comment um in various markets
around the world today
you can actually find uh oil futures
priced in euros
and i'm curious what you think would be
the impact
or the likelihood if other countries
around the world followed iran's lead
and started to quote oil in euros or
another currency as opposed to dollars
okay and did you have a question as well
yes for anyone to take there was very
brief mention here of the derivatives
markets
and we all know the federal reserve and
the other central banks have been
occupied with trying to assess what the
risks are and whether the banks really
understand
truly what these risks are could any of
you comment or whether you think this is
really
a market that is growing beyond the
ability of
any one central bank to control
and the certainly the lack of an
international regulatory
agency okay well um
mike do you want to go i'll take the
last one very very do that very quickly
the answer is yes if you have a global
economy ultimately you need a global
central bank if you ask the heads of
central banks this question they say
well we really don't okay but the answer
is
in the end you do and when we have the
global financial crisis you'll
find it out done
let me uh on the euro question
i think it will be seen as symbolic i
don't think it matters
a great deal so much whether it's priced
in oil or euros because it will just
arbitrage back and forth
what does matter is what happens to
these enormous uh
petrodollar uh reserves that have been
built up and
how those that money is deployed and
where that's deployed
uh i think that looms larger i think on
that other question
uh one you know you don't want to
speculate too much and
broadly but i suppose if you're saying
where could an unexpected shock come
from that would actually hit the system
i would say it would be something that
disrupts the global
supply chains
yeah two comments on kind of leading
indicators of crises
one i think dan's point is is very good
uh supply chains
one thing that's been happening that
nobody's kind of looked at very much
is that more and more production
is moving to fewer and fewer places uh
and so you know you buy a dell laptop
you buy an hp laptop you think you're
getting two different but they come from
the same production lines
uh and so production lines are being
concentrated in places
frequently that are you know higher risk
than higher risk environments is that is
that a new thing i mean you know
30 years ago you bought a car yeah much
forward
i mean the issue is is not if it's new
the question is that it's advanced okay
so
we're at a point where you have um
supply chains that are very extended
and and actually somewhat you know
there's not a lot of competition
in the supply chain so if something
happens to one piece of the supply chain
there's not redundancy that say
redundancy in the supply chain
so the risk of something happening in
supply chain is probably
higher than people recognize second
question
about what could be what could be
leading to a crisis i mentioned earlier
the stealth
move from the dollar
you know keep we have to keep in mind
that this whole system we've been
talking about
and particularly the ability of the
united states to do what it does in
terms of consumption and so forth
we're the only country who can do this
because we print the world's money
nobody else can do this except us so
this all
rests on the rest of the world being
happy to hold dollars
now if you go around and talk as i have
in the last six months to the world's
central bank heads you find a great deal
of nervousness
and you find that banks like bank of
malaysia and new zealand russia
others uh have begun to reduce the
proportion of dollars
in their reserve holdings and move to
euros or other things
very interesting uh movement is is opec
money
uh which has moved significantly into
euros
and there are both economic and
political reasons for doing that
uh and so i think part of the
significance of
of oil futures being
quoted in euros is the potential for a
movement towards
a uh oil price maybe on
on a basket of currencies china
uh is using it's it's not sitting on its
dollar reserves it's buying oil fields
and it's buying iron ore mines it's
buying
commodities it's buying it's buying
basic uh
materials uh and that suggests maybe a
movement
of the world monetary system towards a
commodity based
standard rather than a dollar standard
and there's not a dollar standard the
u.s the sky will fall
uh james calvary that is true but i
think
the dollar standard is micro microphone
i think it's the known microphone i
think the dollar standard i said that is
true but i think the dollar standard is
still
fairly robust because it is not in the
interest
of those who hold dollars to trigger a
run
on the dollar you do not want to be the
bureaucrat in beijing
who reallocated 10 of your portfolio to
euro
and then caused the other 90 to lose
half of its value this would be a very
bad career move i think
i think this conversation though has
been very useful because it has focused
on the structural risks the
architectural risks in the financial
system
and has gotten us away from the kind of
argument which says
that there is anything material about
reducing the trade deficit
next year or over three years or
reducing the budget deficit
that would work on those risks those
risks are there
they're there as a result of the system
we've been in for the last
36 years or so and they will be dealt
with
by one hopes improving regulation
improving coordination between the
central banks
inclu improving our position in the
world and i would say also
by dealing with the underlying problems
of this economy
preventing a slowdown from taking hold
in the short run
and in the long run coming to grips with
what everybody sees
as our social and infrastructural and
environmental
problems and that's where we ought to be
putting our energy
recognizing that we need the
guardianship if you like of the
financial regulators and the larger
guardians of the financial system
but their job is to make possible the
gains that we ought to be making and
leaving for the next generation
okay i think we've been given a slight
stay of execution we can take one more
question there's someone over there
patrick malloy when i was with the
senate banking committee we had what we
used to call the golden rule
which was he who has the gold makes the
rules
and this fits in with a concern that
warren buffett has
that when we run these massive current
account deficits year after year
we're transferring dollars abroad to buy
goods
then the foreigners take these dollars
and buy assets
in this country what warren buffett said
is we're like the rich family living on
the hill
transferring portions of our national
wealth abroad year after year
so he's he's voiced major concerns in an
article
in fortune magazine in october 2003
when our current account was only four
percent now it's closer to seven percent
so he said this is a terrible position
for the united states to be in
we're losing our power position in the
world and it and it's gonna
under undermine our economy in the long
run i just wanted does anybody
share buffett's concerns about what's
going on here
i think buffett's phrase was that we're
becoming a nation of shark rappers
he said we're becoming a sharecropper
economy we're working for the other
people
americans are working for companies and
uh on land which is increasingly owned
by somebody else
that's the idea are you worried mike i'm
i'm not worried
do you think uh the land analogy is an
interesting one but incorrect
okay because you can't make more land
but uh
our national wealth doesn't rest on our
land it's a rest on our ability to be
productive
to come up with new ideas and innovate
and so if you look at the
uh our um if you look at the
the fed statements of household wealth
and you adjusted for
inflation and you adjusted for
government debt
what you see is that despite our trade
deficit despite the fact that we're
selling off pieces of ourself
that we think about a pie we're selling
off pieces of the pie but the pie keeps
getting bigger
and as long as that's happening we're
okay
okay so that's kind of the better
analogy than the land one once you go
for the land you've kind of you've gone
in the wrong direction
okay well i think we've reached a sort
of consensus which i would say is that
um
you know there are problems the sky can
fall you've got the question the doll in
the current account you've got
the question of supply chain disruption
you've got the entitlement things
looming out there which have to be fixed
at some point
but at the same time one shouldn't let
these things blind ourselves to
opportunities that we may be foregoing
if we only look at the problems
because on the other side there are
things that need to be done in terms of
investment in infrastructure investment
in education
investment in the social problems that
uh james garath was talking about
and so it's a question of not letting
the potentially falling sky
obscure the view of what actually needs
to be affirmatively done
to keep the economy moving forward so
i've enjoyed it i hope some of you did
too
thank you very much
tonight's c-span